hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt heute gibt einen leckeren kuchen
wir machen einen leckeren sonntagskuchen
es gibt nämlich eine falsche linzertorte
fragt ihr euch vielleicht was ist eine
falsche linzer torte
ich habe sie neulich bei meiner freundin
gegessen und zwar die linzer torte die
klassische habe ich ja schon mal gemacht
die findet ihr auf meinem kanal da
verlinke ich euch auch das rezept in
meiner infobox die falsche linzertorte
geht ein bisschen einfacher und zwar ist
ein rührteig und da kommt ebenso eine
schicht marmelade dazwischen und wir
hier im badischen wir essen die linzer
torte gerne mit pflaumenmus deswegen
kommt da auch gleich pflaumenmus mit
rein und ich zeige euch jetzt einfach
mal kurz die zutaten und der kuchen ist
wirklich super schnell hergestellt und
ganz einfach zu machen
also ich brauche fünf eier die habe ich
jetzt bereits getrennt in eiweiß und
eigelb 250 gramm butter dies schon
zimmer war eine prise salz etwas vanille
extrakt natürlich 250 gramm zucker dann
habe ich hier ein paar gewürze und zwar
drei teelöffel zimt eine messerspitze
gemahlene nelken und eine messerspitze
gemahlin war ein esslöffel kakaopulver
ein halbes päckchen backpulver das sind
eineinhalb teelöffel dann brauche ich
etwas milch so etwa zwei bis drei
esslöffel da könnt ihr aber zum beispiel
auch ein bisschen obst wasser nehmen
also zum beispiel zwetschen wasser oder
so hier habe ich 250 gramm gemahlene
haselnüsse und zwar habe ich die grad
eben frisch gemahlen im magnetic drei
länder also im hochleistungs mixa habe
ich 150 kamel und ich brauche 200 gramm
pflaumenmus und die samira darf mir ist
dabei helfen und zwar müssen wir jetzt
zuerst das eiweiß steif schlagen
das sorgt jetzt einfach für die
lockerheit
es ist zwar ein rührteig aber dennoch
haben wir teilweise abgetrennt damit der
kuchen richtig schön locker wird da
kommt eine prise salz mit rein
du darfst noch ein bisschen nicht so
viel und es wird jetzt erstmal steif
geschlagen
und sobald steif ist gebe ich noch so
etwa ein drittel vom zucker mit dazu und
zwar müssen wir das eiweiß später
unterheben und es hilft dann einfach
dass es nicht so flockig wird zeige ich
euch da
und der schnee ist jetzt richtig schön
fest das sieht man jetzt hier auch ganz
deutlich
den kann ich jetzt ganz weiteste und
arbeitet in der zweiten schüssel weiter
und zwar kommt da jetzt die weiche
butter rhein zu erstatten löw linderung
und schnee im mund deswegen habe ich das
jetzt schnell gemacht da kommt der
zucker mit drei ja und etwas vanille
extrakt da braucht man nicht so viel und
es früheren wir jetzt so in zwei minuten
schön weiß cremig
jetzt gebe ich hier nach und nach die
eigelbe mit dazu jetzt hast du machen
so hat sich ist alles schön vermischt
jetzt kommen da die trockenen zutaten
rein
die samira halt immer probieren aber war
einfach noch kurz bis der teig ganz
fertig ist dann wieder richtig lecker
als einfach alles zusammen gehen und
lebensart roddick hat echt so zu meinen
absoluten lieblings trocken und ich kann
die aufs ganze jahr über ist also sich
bei mir nicht so dass es nur zum zur
winterzeit gibt wegen den ganzen
gewürzen und dann noch einen teil von
der milch die firma da gehen wir jetzt
erstmal so ein schlückchen betreiben und
dann gucke ich einfach wenn er zu
trocken ist dann gebe ich eben noch den
rest mit ein
jetzt kann ich den eischnee darunter
heben
unser mir schmeckt der teig urteil
ich habe als kind auch gegessen jetzt
schön unterheben und jetzt seht ihr auch
dass sich das schneller mit der
teigmasse verbindet weil ich eben schon
zucker im einschnitten hatte
und wenn man es hat nicht macht dann
lockt der schnee immer so und verbindet
sich eben nicht so schnell
und jetzt habe ich hier bereits eine
form gerichtet und zwar kamen habe ich
auf 26 cm eingestellt und mit backpapier
eingeschlagen
und da fühle ich jetzt die hälfte des
tages rein
landon verstreiche ich den teig können
natürlich auch in einer springform
backen aber in seinem bug rahmen backt
es auch schneller weil man eben ohne
boden backt und praktisch kein
springform boden hat
und jetzt streiche ich da die promenade
rein oder pflaumenmus bild gesagt dass
ich auch mal so schön gewürzt und
deswegen finde ich passt ist immer
perfekt mit dazu kommen auch andere
sachen rein machen schon ja aber warum
laden zum beispiel um etwa für mich
passt netze gut wobei es viele gibt dies
die linzer torte auch mit erdbeer mögen
aber johannesberg passt auch ganz gut
und ich glaube im original aus der stadt
linz wird es auch mit johannesberg
gemacht
und ihr seht auch ich hab das jetzt mehr
so in die mitte gestrichen also nicht
bis zum rand einfach damit dann die
marmelade nicht später am rand raus
läuft jetzt kommen die zweite hälfte vom
tag darauf wird auch glatt gestrichen
und deswegen ist es eben jetzt auch die
falschen worte weil wir dieses glauben
muss darin verstecken und jetzt kein
gitter drauf machen müssen aus mürbeteig
die bei der klassischen linzer torte und
es geht halt so natürlich viel schneller
was so dass ich es so so so nimmt somit
männer variante ja genau die kinder oder
menowin kinder sondern richtig schnelle
einfache variante aber geschmacklich
eben trotzdem druck und das ist auch
schön glatt streichen
und so kommt der kuchen jetzt in den
vorgeheizten backofen bei 180 grad ober
und unterhitze bei einer normalen
springform backte den jetzt etwa eine
stunde
ich muss jetzt ungefähr 40 bis 45
minuten backen weil in dem bug kam das
ganze eben schneller back und das mache
ich jetzt ganz kurz und lasst den kuchen
danach komplett abkühlen und durch magna
schon wieder geld
der kuchen ist es teilweise abgekühlt
sei es jetzt noch ein bisschen lauwarm
team jetzt eigentlich komplett abkühlen
sollen
abkühlen lassen sollen aber dieser mira
geht später noch zum schwimmkurs und
deswegen wollen wir jetzt kurz fertig
machen soll sich den rand einer
mittleren tortenring messer
er riecht schon mal richtig lecker und
da ich auch richtig schön gerade weil es
jetzt so nicht so wirklich nach linzer
torte aussieht habe ich mir gedacht
machen wir doch noch ein geht hat
darüber unsere affekten bitte wir machen
einfach in puderzucker knapp drüber
die türken also jetzt kugel ist getürkt
also im wahrsten sinn des wortes systems
aber ich setze ich ihn erst mal auf die
tortenplatte es auch noch wirklich
bisschen warm
und jetzt habe ich hier so dieter
schneider ist eigentlich und zwar kann
man damit so tolle charlotten machen
also diese kugel trocken kann ich auch
mal machen wir gerne möchte und dann
nehme ich einfach dieses innere oder ihr
habt irgendwie es gibt ja auch dieses
spitzen papier was ihr jetzt drauf legen
könnt oder irgendwas anderes was eben
auch teilweise löcher hat kann man es
auch drauf legen
so jetzt mit puderzucker das süße steht
der schmilzt nämlich nicht an der
oberfläche puderzucker wird jetzt
schmelzen weil der kuchen ja auch jetzt
noch warm ist das heißt ist so eine
richtige ist ruben also ein richtiger
die ins auge fällt also im getötet
es kommt mir etwas spanisch vor diese
redewendung jetzt sollte es geklappt
haben ja wunderbar und jetzt haben wir
trotzdem ein schönes gittermuster von
zwei linzer torte
es braucht relativ einfach schnell
richtig schnell und sehr einfach und
samira möchte es probieren darfst du
probieren
ich finde geschmacklich kommt wirklich
angenehm satt heute dran und das drei
tage kühler und ich bin überhaupt von
tag zu tag mütze in die leckere kann es
sein
es ist halt noch warmen deswegen läuft
so ein bisschen dieses pflaumenmus etwas
raus aber das macht ja nein ich würde
mal sagen heute auf samira verkosten und
nicht der morath okay papa ist mit der
kamera beschäftigt frau thema dann sagst
mal wie es schmeckt okay ich bin
gespannt
also nicht bruder zucker butter zucker
also erst richtig schön saftig und
plauen muss so ein bisschen auf den
boden und jan richtig leckere einfache
rührkuchen und wie schmeckt nur gut oder
sehr gut
kurt morath magst auch probieren das
auch probieren
was auch einfach mal lust hat auf einem
linzer torte genial ganz richtig genial
feste tolles rezept jetzt bin der jetzt
natürlich unter 50 grad hätte wäre es
naiv zu bedanken uns noch nicht abkühlen
kommt nicht 234 stimmen abgelassen mehr
aus kuchen ist noch nicht in kuchen leer
auf jeden fall ein richtig tolles rezept
superschnell gemacht auch noch
hochschwanger cameron nimmt rät die
ganze zeit meine venen gemerkt aber es
ging trotzdem ich habe schon ich habe
schon einmal leben umgestellt was buch
blasen dass die hände waschen
genau ich schreibe das rezept auf jeden
fall auf meinen flug zum ausdrucken zum
herunterladen auf www sallys - und wir
sehen uns beim nächsten mal wieder biss
dann genau morgen morgen machen den
mutterkuchen hahaha ich glaube du bist
echt mein letztes video somit übernahm
bauch rascheln